Freunde guten Morgen aus Barcelona ich
bin hier auf dem la Boqueria eigentlich
im Urlaub mit Lara meiner Freundin
hinter der Kamera und ihrer family aber
wir haben uns davon gestohlen und werden
gemeinsam das kulinarische Barcelona
erkunden keine klassischen Fußball
sondern wir lassen uns treiben mit
Sicherheit wird das Essen brutal hier
gibt es alles was Frisches ich habe
richtig Bock auf einen Saft und was zu
essen deshalb machen wir uns auf die
Suche
wunderschön
ich glaube es ist relativ erkennen dass
hier gefühlt 40° sind deshalb schmelze
ich dahin nicht nur wegen dir sondern
auch wegen den Temperaturen ne haha
[Musik]
das sieht aber gut aus alles Mango
passion fruit and coconut Blueberry
ich würde sagen Prost auf einen guten
Tag
Mango Koch und geil brauchst du
Kokosmilch voll erfrischen nicht so so
dickflüssig oder süß wie es vielleicht
aussieht
leichter wir lassen uns noch ein
bisschen weiter treiben gucken was wir
hier finden der sagt schon mal super
wenn man so auf tiktok schaut und so
sind ja auch vor allem die Säfte und
diese ganzen Früchte und sowas im Fokus
aber hier gibt's auf jeden Fall für
jeden etwas schaut euch das mal an
wirklich wild also wenn man hier in
Barcelona wohnt leider sehr touristisch
aber hier kannst du auf jeden Fall wild
Einkaufen so die Markthalle aber ich
habe Lust etwas
Spannenderes für meinen Gaumen zu finden
und Erik hat mir zum Glück ein
Restaurant empfohlen was absolut krass
sein soll hier sind auf dem Weg zu alway
das ist ungefähr 10 Minuten von dem Ort
wo wir gerade sind Erik hat es
beschrieben wie das Puls aus Barcelona
und das ist in Köln das Restaurant
wir müssen uns jetzt mal hin ausführen
und wir suchen uns was leckeres zu Essen
hoffentlich sind die klimatisiert weil
ich sterbe bei diesem Temperaturen aber
Stadt ist wunderschön
[Musik]
Geschmacks richtig schön hier und was
Eric mir erzählt hat ist das hier brutal
Business Land schreiben
[Musik]
Käse mediterrane pinienkern und
getrocknete orange sind jetzt mit 10,95
€ dabei dass ich ganz günstig ist aber
Vergleich zu Deutschland wenn man das
auf jeden Fall bedeuten teurer bezahlen
glaube ich guck mal der Brief zu
karamellisiert hier oben probieren
brasana Wurst Brie Pinienkerne orange
ich probieren
der Käse nicht so super intensiv aber
alles zusammen brutal also wirklich auch
eine sehr sehr schöne Kreation die
bärisches schweinebäckchen mit
gebuttertem Brot und trüffelcreme ist
dafür gedacht dass in einem bisschen zu
essen und ist diese trüffelcreme
ich muss sagen jetzt schon zwei von vier
Speisen haben wir probiert das ist sehr
sehr im Preis wenn ihr ein Date habt ihr
ein Barcelona ist das hier glaube ich
ein perfekt das war
deutsch
[Musik]
in Rotweinsoße mit getrüffeltem
Kartoffelpüree und die Präsentation ist
wirklich bildhübsch also ich finde
wirklich es ist wunderschön schon fast
und all das kriegt man für 15 € 50 also
im Vergleich zu einem Mac Menü oder
irgendwas ist das auf jeden Fall glaube
ich die bessere Wahl gehen wir jetzt
einmal rein schneide das hier mal an wir
haben das auch in so eine wow
rechteckige Form gebracht und das lässt
sich total zerziehen gehen wir mit ein
bisschen von diesem Rotwein dran und
probiere das ganze mal so für sich boah
ich verstehe warum gefeiert hat also es
ist brutal unfassbar mit ein bisschen
von den Kartoffelpüree an
unser Petersilie und so ein Kristallsalz
drauf her Laden ist brutal jetzt probier
mal ich bin mir sicher du wirst genauso
feiern ich bin gespannt ich nehme alles
mit
[Musik]
du bist heftig oder
vor allen Dingen das ist so das fühlt
sich an wie Sterne essen aber die
Portionen sind größer und es ist echt
bezahlbar für das was es ist
als nächstes haben wir einen
mit weißem Knoblauch und
tataki ihr kennt vielleicht ist außen
gebraten und innen noch leicht rot und
es fühlt sich jetzt schon ultra crispy
an und weich trotzdem
mit anderen Worten also dieser Thunfisch
auch und ich habe ganz vergessen wie
unglaublich saftig das ist nicht umsonst
sagt man dazu das ist Meeres ist das
schmilzt ein möglichst
trotzdem sind wir hier unter 20 Euro und
ich muss wirklich sagen das ist eine
sehr sehr warme Empfehlung von mir für
jeden der ein bisschen Bock auf was
anspruchsvolles hat für ein sehr fairen
Preis ich glaube das war es von dem Spot
war jetzt ein bisschen lang aber wir
gehen zum nächsten das war wirklich
brutal das Wort gerade also Würste nicht
was mir jetzt noch fehlt außer
vielleicht
und schoß das ist gut bewertet keine
Ahnung was man bei Churros richtig oder
falsch machen kann
[Musik]
kannst du mir auch geben
da haben wir sechs Stück glaub danach
müssen wir natürlich halb Barcelona
laufen und wieder was essen zu können
aber ich muss jetzt schon sagen
Barcelona ist glaube ich eine Stadt die
hast du auf jeden Fall nicht mit einem
Tag aus erzählt ich glaube hier gibt so
viel krasses Essen viel krasses Essen
glaube ich auch als in den meisten
deutschen Städten ich habe auch so ein
heftigen chicken Sport gefunden Smash
Burger auch so die Küche die nicht lokal
ist von hier ist unglaublich gut deshalb
mal schauen was hört noch alles schaffen
aber ich könnte auf jeden Fall mehrere
Tage nur mit Essen hier zu bringen aber
wir wollen ja auch meinen Geschäft
gucken und so oder Larry
ja so Freunde eine kurze Stärkung GoPro
zwischendurch Navi und ich sind gerade
auf den Rammler ihr seht so kleine
Geschäft überall jede Menge Menschen
soweit das Auge reicht wir sind
unterwegs zu einem Sport der macht frei
schicken und dort durfte ich schon mal
essen ich sage euch ehrlich das ist so
mit das krasseste frei chicken was hier
gegessen habe vielleicht sogar fast so
gut wie selbst schicken in Kalifornien
wir sind unterwegs dahin und schauen wir
mal was es gibt
so Freunde letzter Spot wir sind vor
Rock darf ich gerade hin zeige und dort
gibt es eben brutales chicken wir gehen
jetzt hin ich habe Bock mir noch mal den
Rest zu geben mit so einem spicy chicken
Sandwich lass uns reingehen und ein
gebührendes Ende für diesen sehr
leckeren und sehr schönen Tag hier in
Barcelona finden
[Musik]
junge das sieht krank aus was für ein
Ende für diesen wunderbaren Tag an dem
ich sehr lecker gegessen habe ein spicy
chicken Sandwich mit Limetten Mayo und
guckt euch einmal dieses chicken piece
an was da drauf ist brutal er hat mich
gefragt willst du spicy oder super super
spicy ich habe mich für Spice
entschieden nehmen wir das mal weg damit
ihr seht und rein da
huhu was ist denn super super spicy gut
dass ich nicht genommen habe Alter
wirklich richtig geil das Brot ist
wahrscheinlich sogar Homepage der Burger
zwei Gläser Wasser 10 € kann man gar
nichts sagen und zwischen den ganzen
lokalen Spezialitäten eine sehr
willkommene Abwechslung
mein erster dabei
in diesem
Video ist toll
umgearbeitet damit die Stadt brutal Wahl
sage manchmal vorkommt dieses chicken
ist nicht Müller das werden nicht viele
verstehen von mir bester Fotograf
Deutschland und er ist der Chicken Mann
und er weiß wo es krasses gibt
und er sagt dass das hier gut ist
deshalb
habe selten so viel geschwitze in dem
Video wie heute entschuldigung dass ich
das gestört hat aber danke fürs zusehen
auch hier wieder wärmsten empfohlen es
war wirklich geil heute also ich kann
alles empfehlen der erste Spot vor allem
ist nicht gut ist
gut Leute